we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is a great question
about
what would trump be doing now if the
situation were reversed take a listen to
this
what would they do if the circumstances
were reversed
and biden were sick they would move in
for the kill
i think right i think it that there's a
parallel between the number of people
that trump has allowed to get sick and
the fact that he allowed himself
and his people in his entourage to get
sick it just goes to show
he's unfit and they would show no mercy
if the situation
were reversed so maybe you want to do a
show about that
there is absolutely no question about it
you know joe biden when donald trump was
was positive for coronavirus immediately
announced he was pulling negative ads
that he was sending his best wishes
barack obama sent best wishes you even
had anchors like on msnbc
talking about trump's new tone and all
of this stuff
and meanwhile as donald trump is being
airlifted to walter reed hospital
amid a cloud of dishonesty and and
uh confusion about his actual condition
the trump campaign is sending out
fundraising emails about
lion's sleepy joe and all of this insane
conspiratorial nonsense that they email
people about all the time
trump is back on twitter already it is
abundantly clear
that joe biden has done everything right
joe biden's campaign events
abide by the cdc guidelines joe biden
despite
having been on stage with what was
likely a contagious trump during that
first debate
has fortunately as of this moment of
recording tested negative for
coronavirus three times
joe biden just needs to keep running a
campaign period
and you know negative that he's gonna
run positive ads but not negative ads
criticizing trump on policy is fair game
we have an election someone is going to
be president the next four years
and i think that it is if if it was
reversed just imagine
they would be running ads saying weak
biden got the virus
masks don't work because biden wore a
big mask and got the virus anyway
imagine if you got it from trump while
being on stage during a moment
where supposedly everybody on stage had
been tested and tested negative
they would be running negative ads they
wouldn't stop anything there is no
question about it i don't think there is
anything wrong with joe biden simply
continuing to campaign
we have a great bonus show for you today
what's going to happen with the
confirmation of amy coney barrett
as a result of trump testing positive
because it's not just trump
mike lee and two other republican
senators ron johnson
and one more i forget the name have
tested positive
if they can't be there plus murkowski
and collins
won't vote before the election they
don't have the votes
so we're going to talk about that and
more and more things are pointing to the
lame duck
period regal cinemas is closing
all cinemas in the united states and the
united kingdom on thursday
are we seeing the beginning of the end
of the movie theater industry
and lastly 11 positive coronavirus tests
have now been traced
specifically to the presidential debate
according to cleveland officials we are
going to talk about
whether they will have any ability to
enforce the rules
if debates number two and three happen
and of course
at the vice presidential debate which
still as of right now
and things changed so quickly which is
why i say it that way as of right now
is still scheduled for this wednesday
night at 9 00 pm eastern time if indeed
the debate happens wednesday night the
vp debate i will be streaming
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me for what i think
will be
an absolute brutalizing of mike pence
by kamala harris